it can instantly cause severe burns on
your skin it can even dissolve things
like limestone and concrete this is
battery acid what if we decided to fill
80% of our world with it specifically
what if we decided to turn our oceans
into acid what would this acid mean for
ocean wildlife what might swimming in
this be like and how would it affect our
cities this is what if and here's what
would happen if the oceans turned to
acid to put what we're about to do in
perspective our oceans have a pH of
around 8 pH levels are a measure of how
acidic or basic a solution is battery
acid has a pH of 0 right at the bottom
of the scale meaning it is incredibly
acidic and scientists are expecting
something like this to happen with 100%
of the Arctic Ocean becoming corrosive
ly acidic by the year 2100 but what if
we speed this up and make it affect all
of our oceans first we should figure out
why something like this is happening
well due to climate change
the ocean is absorbing more carbon
dioxide than ever and when that happens
it dissolves and reacts with the water
creating carbonic acid over time this
can cause our oceans to become
incredibly acidic harming fish coral
reefs and even the ocean floor itself
if something like this were to happen
overnight it's safe to say that all the
fish you like to eat would be killed and
would be quickly dissolved by the acid
there are nearly 230,000 different
species in the ocean and that's just
what we've found scientists estimate
that there are over 2 million more
species we have yet to discover so tons
of fish would be dead but what about
more robust fish like sharks well
although they have a much thicker skin
they would dive relatively quickly as
well so would mammals like dolphins and
whales
now what about crustaceans like lobsters
and crabs well they definitely have a
better chance of surviving due to their
hard shells protecting them but that
would only happen if the oceans
gradually got more acidic with it
happening instantly every species in the
ocean would go extinct and even if a
species could miraculously survive
losing all the others would destroy the
food chain so they would go extinct as
well
now what if something like this happened
over the course of 100 years would all
the creatures in the ocean be able to
adapt well no
something like this happened 55 million
years ago and even though it took place
over thousands of years
it caused a mass extinction event so
regardless of how long it takes for the
oceans to turn to acid it would kill any
living creature within it
so now with all the fish dead what's
left in our oceans
well the coral reefs might be able to
hold out a bit longer but they won't
last forever once they start to dissolve
we'll also begin to see these oceans of
acid affect what we have on land our
oceans already dissolve and erode our
coastlines but slowly but once our
oceans turn to acid the process would
occur much faster over time the oceans
would start to take over our land
gradually dissolving coasts and then
making its way to our houses and
eventually our cities and since this was
all caused by global warming which
increases the chance of hurricanes
imagine these acid waters flooding our
streets if that were to happen our homes
buildings and roads would all start to
dissolve and fall apart and it would
inevitably make contact with your skin
causing it to burn yeah swimming in this
acid would be out of the question and as
this happens more and more millions of
people would become injured will die and
the oceans would start to take over the
earth
anyone who managed to survive maybe up
on a mountain top would eventually be
left with nothing
so turning our oceans into acid would be
a horrific idea if we do want to mess
around with acid maybe we should take
some stomach acid and fill a swimming
pool with it and how about we try
jumping into it just to see what happens
yeah we'll leave that story to another
what-if
[Music]